Let us first consider a simpler sentence. So
consider the sentence Ashok made pancakes for David with a griddle.
I'm sure you understood the meaning of this sentence almost immediately. But
what did you understand? What is the meaning of meaning? We can do several
different kinds of analysis on this sentence. We can do lexical analysis,
which will categorize each of these words into different lexical categories. For
example, Ashok is a noun, made is a verb, pancakes is a noun, and so on. We can
do syntactic analysis. In terms of the structure of this particular sentence.
So, you might say Ashok is a non phrase. Made pancakes for David with a griddle
is a verb phrase. And this particular verb phrase itself has sub phrases in it.
Or we can do semantic analysis on this, and say that Ashok was the agent.
Made was the action. Pancakes were the object that got made. David was
the beneficiary. Griddle was the instrument. The knowledge base here as
oppose to understanding stories like this. Semantic analysis is at a forefront.
Syntactic analysis and lexicon analysis will serve semantic analysis. So
here are some of the semantic categories in terms of which we can classify
the different words in the sentence. So Ashok is an agent, made is an action or
verb in the lexical sense, pancakes are the thematic objects,
the things that are getting made and so on. The frame for representing
understanding of this sentence has the verb of the action make, the agent Ashok,
and so on just like we just discussed. This then is the meaning of meaning. This
is what the agent understands when it understands the meaning of this sentence.
This is perhaps also what you understand when you understand the meaning of
this sentence. How do we know that you understood the meaning of this sentence?
Well, we know that because I can ask you some questions and you can draw
the right kind of inferences from it. So for example, given this sentence,
I can ask you, well who ate the pancakes? And you might be able to say,
well David ate the pancakes because Ashok made the pancakes for David.
Notice that this information about who ate the pancakes was not present in this
particular sentence. This is an inference you're drawing. This is a very similar
to what we had encountered earlier when we had sentence like Ashok ate a frog.
At that time too, we'd ask questions like, well, was Ashok happy at the end?
And the frame had some default values which said Ashok was probably happy.
Or, was the frog dead at the end, and the frame for
eating had some default value which said that the frog was dead at the end?
So according to this theory, the meaning lies in the inferences we can draw from
it. You understand the meaning of this if you can draw the right inferences. You
do not understand the meaning of this if you cannot draw the right inferences or
if you can draw only the wrong inferences. This frame representation of
the meaning of this particular sentence allows you to draw the right inferences.
Given the action make here, the thematic role pertains to the relationship of
various words in the sentence. To this particular action of making.
Ashok is the agent, David is the beneficiary, and so
on. So far we are describing meaning of this sentence, and how we
can capture that meaning in this frame. We have not yet described the process by
which this knowledge is extracted out of that sentence. The extraction of
the meaning of this sentence is exactly the topic that we will discuss next.